Hey hi doctor how you doing okay sir
thank you how can we help you all right
all right
we've been following you for a while
there not to speaking of Drew Pearson I
decided okay go ahead and take a chance
it's a great product the Hail Mary pass
guy yes sir absolutely spoke to him
several times and he'd speak highly of
you
well I'm here's the thing I'm my weight
I'm about 300 maybe about 40 pounds and
I just recently purchased the Healthy
Start pact with the with the Rev but it
was kind of conflicting to that it was
wondering how many I should buy and so I
said let me give you a call because I've
always been listening to your program
and how are you Maurice Oh Jonathan
5:11 okay do you have any other issues
I've been some type of pressure
arthritis have enough pressure um
charmagne what would you do for this guy
he's just short a six foot tall weighs
one hundred three hundred and forty
pounds he's 140 pounds overweight got
some high blood pressure what would you
do for this guy well for his issues and
everything that he he needs at least
three healthy brain and heart back side
get him on and four high and four other
issues he needs the yelled from a daily
classic and he obviously can keep taking
the road okay exactly right so charge
exactly correct here Maurice so you need
to get rid of all the bad foods the
fried foods the process meats the oils
the glutens no wheat bran oats and then
ideally you would take three of the
healthy brain and heart attacks or month
three healthy brain and heart attacks or
month cost your problem don't kind of
lower it any lower than two per month
okay otherwise you're going to see much
and then I would also get a hold of the
what would you give for the high blood
pressure Charmaine well for that issue
yeah I'd go ahead and get three bottles
a month to the ultimate daily classic
tablets you can get three of those
tablets at breakfast lunch and dinner
time and they're designed to support
healthy blood pressure and healthy blood
flows or blocked arteries and as Sean
said you want the Rev re V to support
healthy weight loss and I would get two
bottles is you know one for every fifty
pounds you want to lose you know you
need to lose 100
forty pounds I would go with two bottles
of the Rev take a dropper full not a
drop it or drop or fall under your
tongue 30 minutes for each meal put a
second dropper full under your tongue 15
minutes for each meal leave it absorbs
her old fishes you swallowed it won't
hurt you but you won't get maximum
benefit and within a couple of days or
so you'll begin to lose a half a pound
of 2 pounds a day and the miracle will
be you won't gain the weight back as
long as you stay in the 90s sense of
nutrients appropriate for body weight
because being overweight and obese has
nothing to do with EEMs much or lack of
exercise being overweight and obese is
in fact a deficiency if any one of the
members of a certain class of nutrients
there's three of them if you're
deficient in any one of those you're the
300-pound person the 500 pound purse or
the 800 pound person and I actually run
into hundreds of people with this issue
every every year of course Shar sees a
lot of them also in our in our daily
lives as well as on the radio like
yourself and so we can tell you if you
do this thing right you're going to be a
great great testimony for people who
have similar problems so I urge you to
get started and then give us a call
every two weeks and we will walk you
through this